hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we're here in Milan and I just thought
the dolce gabbana show and it was
amazing it was all about coats they had
tons of beautiful coats it actually
opened with a cape it was very cool a
hooded cape there was also lots of
embroidery which is really beautiful on
jackets on some of the shoes on the
socks I also really love those this
amazing pair of studded boots that was
really cool there was these really great
silk pajamas that were amazing overall
the colors were really black and gray
very good for fall one of the great
thing was a lot of the coats are perfect
for over your regular suit that you
might just have in your closet and
they're not too bulky which is wonderful
because they'll still give you a really
slim silhouette which is great they had
all these amazing bow ties that were
very messy they were loosely tied I'm
just a really fresh way to wear a bow
tie for fall winter 2012-13
it's a beautiful collection for more
info follow me on twitter at details
matt and also check out details calm for
more videos throughout the week